- You know how many 49-year-old men
do not believe in themselves?
- Yep.
- Most.
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Gary, I think one of
the things we wanna hit on
is women entrepreneurs
Angela and I have owned
our own business now
for seven years.
- Amazing.
- We work together and
we are a partnership
and we actually still
really like each other.
We actually like each other even more
than we did when we began.
- That means you guys are communicating.
- We are.
- Oh 100%.
- I think we communicate more
than I sometimes communicate
with my husband.
- That makes a lot of sense.
- Her husband gets really jealous, too.
(laughing)
- Because we spend a lot of time together.
- It makes sense.
- Yeah,
and you have to, right?
- Yeah. You know, a lot of
people that are confused
about entrepreneurs, they don't realize
that the business is
the other family member.
- Yeah, 100%.
- Oh, it's so true.
- I mean, it just is.
A business is another
child, another spouse.
It's intense.
It's the output of people's passion.
I look at business as more like friends.
You know, like you don't get to choose
who you're born into
as parents or siblings
but you do pick your
friends and a lot of times
that's why those are the most
meaningful relationships.
You do get to pick your business.
- You do and you create
this culture, right?
And you create this family.
Like we have our Theory Family
that is our staff, it's our
spouses, it's our coach.
It's everybody and we have this culture
and it's our clientele.
Like it's not just selling to us,
it's creating this lifestyle
with people that we love.
- Not only that, when you
then start breaking down
how many hours you work.
- It's not work.
- [Woman] It's not work to us at all.
- Listen, I get that and
that's why it's working.
- Yeah.
- But, you start cutting down
how much time you work on your not work,
or your work, or your
business, or your product
and you start realizing
my god, my profession,
my career, my passion, you know,
if you're lucky enough like you guys are,
is the majority of what
I spend my time on.
- Yes.
- Very true, very true.
- I think that's why I'm so passionate
about communicating my points of view
on what the internet has created.
I mean, looking at the
five of us, none of us
were born into a world where
this much opportunity existed.
Our parents and grandparents
did not have this opportunity.
They just didn't.
- No.
- The internet is like electricity.
It's like running water and I don't think
we've understood that.
Electricity and running water lead to like
better quality of life day-to-day.
The internet leads to happiness
if you choose to harness it.
- Oh, 100%.
- It's a big deal.
- [Woman] It's so hard to teach
that you can be happy, right?
You can go outside of those restraints
that you have put on yourself.
- Everybody was taught to go to school
and stay within a system.
- [Woman] Or what about a woman?
You were taught to be a mom, right?
And stay at home.
That's a huge thing that we push back
in our small community
because Angela's a mom
and I'm not and I've
chosen to run the business
and not have kids.
She's chosen to be a working mom.
- [Angela] But then I have
that, you know, struggle, right?
- Yeah, and I think both of you
probably have that struggle.
I think everybody has struggle, right?
- [Angela] Yeah.
- As soon as you were just saying that
I'm like oh, that's good.
Why I said that's good in my head is
I'm a very big believer
that if you see anybody
in your circumstance succeed in happiness,
forget about money, well then you can too.
You know, like if
there's anybody out there
who was born into two parents
that were addicted to heroin
and were never around and that person
went on to achieve
happiness then every child
who sees that person can point to that.
I think it's very powerful
to be co-founders.
One who does have a
family and one who doesn't
because your audience then
gets to see themselves
in one of you.
- That's very true.
- I think that's incredible.
- [Woman] So, Gary, our big question is
how do we get that out more?
Our sort of story.
- Content.
- [Woman] I think we
struggle every single day
with our business.
- Content.
- But we do a ton of content.
- More.
- [Woman] More.
(laughing) We knew you were
going to say that, too.
- Because it's the actual answer.
Even take this, right?
You're filming this.
- [Woman] Yes, we brought them with us.
- I see that.
I see this as, in my
mind, in that free deck
that I put out, right?
The Gary Vee Content Model.
I see today right now
as 34 pieces of content.
- Easily.
- That's right.
That is the answer.
- Yeah.
That is easily.
- I agree.
The fact that you answered so easily,
that means you guys are halfway home.
Now it's just execution
and maybe you're doing
that too, I don't know.
But I can tell you that up
until I put out that deck,
until I started getting loud
about how I do the content,
a lot of podcasters, 99% of them, see this
as one piece of content.
- [Woman] Oh, no, it's
a lot more than that.
- Do you understand?
- Yeah.
He pushes us over there to do it.
To do even more.
- So the answer is more.
I mean, it's like how do
you get bigger muscles?
You work out more.
You know, how do you lose more fat?
How do you get your heart healthier?
You know?
The answer is more.
I was saying something to
Brandon, my best friend
who runs Wine Library now
and who I built Wine Library with,
who I've known since I was
14 doing baseball cards
and I said something to
him. This is a true story.
This happened only a couple hours ago.
I was telling him about
my ambitions for him
as an executive at Wine
Library and why I think
we can be way more successful next year.
I said to him something pretty powerful
that I never really articulated.
I said, Brandon, you know
the guy that you worked with
those 12 years?
The one that you admire
and think is the best?
I currently, in my current
form as a businessman,
as a person, as a
father, a husband, a man,
I view that guy that
was me only a decade ago
and I referenced a former employee of ours
who was like a C minus,
and it really took him back
and it's actually the truth.
I can't believe how much better I am today
than I was 10 years ago and I thought
I was the best 10 years ago.
You can imagine, one of the
things that I'm most proud of
is I only give advice I took.
Over the last 10 years,
I have become better.
There's nothing else to say.
I've become better.
- But how do you
become better is mainly the main question.
- One step at a time.
- Yeah, patience.
(laughing)
Patience.
- Your question was
very, very basic, right?
Very easy to understand.
You said how do we get
our message out more?
- Yes.
- My answer
was more content.
You have a podcast.
I want you to transcribe this interview
into a LinkedIn post.
I want you to write a medium post.
I want you to have your own
blog on your own website.
I want you to take seven
quotes from this interview
and put pictures over it.
I want you to take seven
clips and put it on Facebook.
I want you to put it on YouTube.
I want you to put three one-minute clips
from this on YouTube.
Like I want you to make an infographic
of what I'm saying right now of like how
we're going to make more content chart.
I mean, more, more,
more, more, more, more.
- [Woman] How do you find the time?
Oh, I know you're going to answer that.
(laughing)
- No, I appreciate it.
- [Woman] We're already
running the business
like a ton.
- Look, I see two people
here whether they're working
for free or getting paid.
You buy time.
- Very true.
- You buy time.
- Yeah, leveraging.
- Correct, you buy time.
- That's exactly
what we did with them
coming with us, right?
- I see that, I see them.
- [Woman] Because it's kind
of like a dream for them
and Camille loves you so
we brought them along.
(laughing)
That is the way we've
always done our business.
It's not about us number one,
it's about who we can bring
with us on the journey.
- That becomes a selfless
act that is selfish
because it makes you happy.
- It does.
Very true, very true.
- I understand it, me too.
Like the four-minute conversation
I had with Jason yesterday
like makes me pumped, right?
Like getting so close
to Seth and seeing him
get engaged last week.
- Congratulations!
(laughing)
- Like to me, I genuinely get happiness
from other people getting happy
mainly because I'm pretty
emotionally fulfilled.
- Yes.
- Once you're happy, what?
The only logical next step is
to make other people happy.
There is no more.
So I get it but the
answer is you have to make
your actions map your ambitions.
So I have no idea how big you want to be.
- Big.
- Great.
- [Woman] I'm the one that drives that.
- So you basically have to...
- I'm happy.
- Understood.
So you basically have to
leave short-term vanity things
because if you want to be big,
then you have to make sacrifices.
- [Woman] But did you let go of control
for that to happen?
- Yeah, 100%.
- [Woman] And that's a difficult thing.
- If you talk to me team right now
they'll tell you the level of autonomy
that I give them creatively
and process-wise is?
- [Woman] And how long did it
take you to get to that point?
- I've always been basically at that point
because that was a
natural strength of mine
realizing practically.
See, the interesting thing about me
that I don't talk a whole lot about
is I would argue that I'm
disproportionally more practical
than I am emotional and
people are confused by that
because I'm so high-energy
and I'm so vibed out
that it disguises my
level of practicality.
I haven't been able to build
these 80, 200 million dollar
businesses out of charisma,
it's been operational.
So very quickly, I realized
scale came in 98 people
doing a seven of my 10,
versus one person doing a 10.
- [Angela] That's so hard to let go.
- It's not really hard if
you're fortunate enough
to not have an ego.
(laughing)
- [Woman] You nailed it.
- I mean it, I mean it, I mean it.
And honestly, it's a fun thing to say
mainly because, you know, ego
is just insecurity disguised.
- Very true.
- That is so true.
- But listen, and you'll appreciate this.
I have empathy.
The hardest thing to let
go is the image of oneself.
You know, it's one thing
if you're letting go
of how people stock your
shelves at a liquor store,
which I did, which my dad couldn't.
- Yeah.
- Or a million other things.
I've let go the most
valuable thing of all.
They are actually 100%
in control of my image.
- I love it.
- I mean, I do not micro-manage.
It's absurd when you
think about the level.
Here's why.
I believe the truth always wins.
So if Seth went rogue.
I mean, Seth tomorrow could not leave.
He could literally record
the first two minutes
of the podcast and be like
hey, guys, this is Seth.
Let me actually tell you the
truth about Gary Vaynerchuck.
(laughing)
- [Woman] I love how he's laughing.
- But like I would never know.
There is no checks and balances.
I blindly trust Seth.
Mainly because I know who I actually am.
The reason I'm not scared
is every mistake is fixable
when the truth and good is on your side.
- [Woman] 100%, I totally believe that.
- We had an incident happen on Friday.
- [Woman] Yeah, and we actually went down
to a really good place instead
of going to a bad place.
- Yeah.
- Being the bigger person.
- Is always the move.
- Yeah, and I had to be.
I made a huge mistake.
- Great.
- It's a constant reminder
each day and every
moment to be that person.
- And I learned from it.
- Let me tell you this,
the world doesn't get upset
at you for the mistake.
It gets upset at you for the coverup.
- Yes.
- And she phoned the client.
She phoned them and told them the truth.
- I was like I'm so sorry
and she's like, Angela,
I thought honestly
something bad was happening.
I'm like I did, I forgot
to order your chairs.
She's like no, that's not a mistake.
She's like that's not
the end of the world.
To me, because it was my ego.
- 100%.
- But you owned the mistake.
- I owned the mistake.
I 100% owned and she was okay with it.
- Not everybody is going
to own the mistake.
You don't own it right away,
hence why you had to
get to that part, right?
- Well, I was shocked.
I was actually, yeah,
because I was 100% shocked.
I actually was like oh, my god.
- [Gary] I basically live
my life expecting to make
substantial mistakes on a daily basis.
Mainly because humans are flawed.
I mean, the biggest
problem with our society
right now is hypocrisy.
All we do is deploy judgment on others
while we're doing something
else that's wrong.
- [Women] I think we find, as females,
that we judge each other even more
so when you talk about like
being a mom and working,
or me not having kids,
I'm judged all the time.
- Of course, and honestly,
you'll appreciate this.
I've looked at that issue a little bit
out of curiosity.
- It's a big issue.
- It's big.
- It's a very big issue and I think
it's a proper reaction
from women in our society
because I, I, as a white
male, come from a place
of abundance.
I don't think there's
limited spots, women do.
- [Woman] Oh, women really do
because you're always competing
for that number one spot.
- [Angela] The number one spot.
- Or that only spot
amongst all the other spots
because only one woman can
fill it, not eight guys.
So, you know, I have a lot of empathy
to how women got there.
I'm just hopeful that the next century
it will dissolve over time.
- [Angela] I hope so.
I hope instill that into my daughter
that, you know, don't judge
other women, you know?
- Don't judge anybody.
- I'm obsessed right now on judgment.
I'm just so angry and I don't get angry.
I'm angry at people's ability to judge
with deep levels of
hypocrisy on the back end.
I am sure of the following statement:
every person I've ever seen in society
has done things that they're not proud of.
- Oh.
- 100%.
Definitely.
- Yeah.
- Everybody has.
- I know it.
I know it's a fact.
- [Angela] They're lying.
- Thus, I don't have the
capability of judging
somebody else's life.
I don't know what's going
on in their bedroom,
in their house, in their
head, in their relationship.
I just hate judging.
I'm crippled by judgment.
I hate it.
I want to eliminate it.
- Yeah.
I feel the same way.
- You know, as meditation
has become a big thing
in our culture, I don't
meditate, but I kind of live
a very thoughtful,
mindful, spiritual, macro,
intriguing mindset life.
I often say that I live in a cocoon.
I go to myself.
I'm self-soothing.
You know, it's funny, when
you asked that question
I literally thought about
a cat licking itself.
(laughing)
- [Woman] That's what
popped into your head?
- I've never used this analogy ever.
I know my team has never heard this.
(laughing)
I think you're going to
find this really funny.
This is true.
I don't know why cats lick themselves.
I guess that's how they bathe themselves?
- [Woman] They clean themselves.
They clean themselves, yeah.
- I would tell you that I
do a mental version of that.
I am within myself.
I am not in need of an outside
or other force to navigate
what's going on in my life.
I've also never experienced
the death of somebody
disproportionately close to me
because I lost all my
grandparents except for one
and didn't have a very large family.
So here I am at 43 years old
and not losing my parents,
siblings, children, spouse.
So, you know, I'm maybe
going to need it then.
The only thing I really do care about
is those 11, 12, 13 people.
Like, I wish people actually
knew how real that is to me.
I think people say it and
then they're not truthful.
People say all I care about is my family
but then I watch their
actions and it's not true.
I don't go to anybody, I go to myself.
I do, I go to myself in
my sleep, in my showers,
in my flights, in those
moments where I have a second
to myself where I'm not
working every second,
I go to myself.
- [Woman] That's amazing, I'm jealous.
- And honestly, a lot of
what I'm trying to put
into the world, is trying
to get people into that.
Lately, I've been doing, you know,
I've done a keynote recently.
I've been doing this kind of like...
I've only done this
shtick now a couple times
where I put my fingers in my ears.
Like my happiness comes from this.
- [Angela] Great advice.
- You know, I can't hear anybody.
You know, when you can't
hear anybody for real.
I want to really go here right now.
- [Angela] You don't even
hear your wife in your ear?
- I do not hear my wife.
- Come on, Gary.
- I don't.
(laughing)
And it's funny, you went there
and that's where I was about to go.
In its truth, in its purest form,
when you don't hear your
spouse or your parents
or your children, that's it.
That's why I am who I am.
I don't hear it.
- That's a really tough place
to get to.
- Yeah.
- [Woman] Because it feels like everybody
always wants something from you.
So you're basically like...
- [Angela] Especially you.
You're probably pulled in
like a million different directions.
- Guys, I mean, I look, I
think I have a unique life
for a reason.
I really do know that.
Like I do know that.
I don't have this admiration
or success or notoriety.
The thing that's happening with me
is the byproduct of who I am.
A couple things, back to ego and security,
confidence, all that stuff.
A I don't think I did that.
I think Gary Vee is the byproduct
of Tamara and Sasha
Vaynerchuck, the byproduct
of capitalism in America.
Like the byproduct of a kid
who was born with nothing
and had to earn his keep.
- [Angela] That's true, yeah.
- So when people are like...
When these nice feelings that I'm getting
from you guys come, you'd be so surprised
how much that doesn't go to me,
which keeps me
disproportionately grounded.
- [Woman] So that's how
you don't have an ego.
- That's exactly right.
- Exactly.
- You know, and it's
like I have confidence.
- [Woman] Yeah, you definitely
have a lot of confidence.
- Tons.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- But I have such disproportionate
amounts of humility
because I'm aware of the truth, which is
I had less to do with this.
I think people are confused
that they're the byproduct
of much more than they are.
I think they're children,
they're businesses.
Like my pride in my children
and definitely my businesses
will be very high because
that's me architecting.
My community, I'm very proud of.
The positivity and
positivity with non-delusion
is very difficult to create.
I don't want to be the secret, you know?
I don't even want to be
Tony Robbins or Oprah.
I've got a different kind
of slight gear to it,
which comes with a level of practicality
and accountability and lack of entitlement
that is a little bit
different and I do think
that's why it's happening, but
it's very quiet in my head.
Very, very, very quiet.
I am disproportionately not anxious.
- [Angela] It's tough not to have anxiety.
- I agree.
As anxiety has grown in our society...
- [Angela] It's completely grown.
You don't sleep at night.
- I'm less anxious than I've ever been.
- [Woman] Well, I didn't sleep last night
because I was so excited to meet you.
- I get excited.
(laughing)
I don't sleep before a big Jets game.
That, I understand.
That's called excitement.
But worrying doesn't come natural to me
because I feel in control
and here's where being quiet helps.
I am so comfortable if I make
13 bad business decisions,
lose everything, every
article on Earth is written.
See, I told you, he was full of shit.
He wasn't good.
He wasn't as good as he thought.
This is why don't be the
next Gary Vee as a headline.
That doesn't bother me.
I'll tell you why.
Number one: if I go on to lose everything
from a business standpoint,
I deserve those headlines.
Number two: I don't care.
Because I feel capable of coming back
and then I get to rise like a Phoenix
and then do it all again.
So I think being quiet in
your head is a big deal.
I'm not worried about who
thinks I'm ugly or stupid
or full of shit or not capable
or not as good as I think.
You know, it's funny.
I respect it, I hear it,
but I don't consume it.
I definitely don't internalize it
and I don't live my life predicated on it.
- [Angela] So are you going to
be teaching lessons on this?
- You know, I think I'm doing it.
- [Both Women] You are.
- [Woman] You really
are because we listen to
and do all of...
Like, we listen to all your like podcasts
and YouTube and everything
and it has completely changed
the way that I think.
- Changed us.
- [Woman] And before I say something
I think with the
comparison or the judgment
or getting upset when Angela
makes a mistake at work.
I actually take a couple minutes now.
- You don't even know.
Like I wish there was
data on the chemicals
that are going through my
body when I listen to you
because I believe you and
let me tell you something,
as you continue to go through the process,
it's bonkers.
It's just...
- Oh, 100%.
- It just gets better and
better and better and better.
- [Woman] You actually feel so much better
because you're not bringing
home all that negativity.
Like if I get upset at
work, I don't want to
bring it home because I don't
want to even have it at work.
Because people are with us all day.
- Once you start actually letting go
and realize you weren't
in control of it anyway.
- [Woman] Yeah, never.
- [Angela] It's so true.
- You know why I give full autonomy?
What, am I gonna sit on Seth's head
and just watch what he does?
That's why I have scale.
You want to build something big?
It's about fundamentally
letting go of everything
except the one percent
of things that matter,
which are your actions.
- Very true.
- Yeah.
We've learned that now.
All ladies.
There's 10 of us that work together
and we're all ladies and
we get along like a family,
which is very rare.
- It makes me really happy.
I said in the beginning and I'm saying it
towards the end now, it's communication.
It's empathy, it's
kindness, it's gratitude.
It's these soft skills.
And look, for me, the most exciting thing
that's happening in my life,
which is a very similar thing
to what's going on with
you, but I don't think
people see it as obviously with me.
So you guys must be disproportionate,
I could sense it, proud about
the impact you're having
on female entrepreneurship and happiness.
- Definitely.
- Yes.
- I think an underlying
thing that I don't see
and I don't think people
realize what I'm actually up to.
When I tell you the level
of pride that I have
that I'm rewiring 15 to
25-year-old alpha males
and making things that
have never been cool
to alpha men cool like
empathy, like kindness,
like gratitude, that is very far away
from bottles and models
and hooking up and money
and private jets.
I mean, the stark difference between what
these kids are getting from
me on my Instagram feed
versus what they're getting
from almost everybody else,
the level of impact that
I will have on society
if I pull this off to
the level that I think
I'm pulling it off, is remarkable.
Because there's very few
people that are capable
to penetrate a 17-year-old
kid for that kid
to think that that person's cool to change
their mindset that then
stuffs them once they think
that person's cool with
propaganda of being
a kind and awesome human being.
- [Angela] So true.
- [Woman] And I think, Gary,
for us what we want to do
is do the exact same
thing but with females.
Especially females that
maybe have been mothers
stay at home for 18 years
and then their kids leave
and they don't know who they are
and they've never done
anything with their life.
Because we see a lot of
people right now that are kind
and they're lost.
- You know what's amazing?
What's amazing when you say that sentence,
what just transpired.
I see you, Tyler, we're about to leave
and this is a great way to end.
I, as an operator, and I know
this is not how you meant it
but I want to tell you what
just happened in my brain.
18 years never did
anything with their life,
you're talking about professional.
- Professional, yeah.
- I know.
I know.
- I'm not meaning anything
against children.
- I know.
That's why I hedged it up front.
These skills to manage
one to four children,
very different because you love them
in a different way than your employees,
but give me a 52-year-old woman
who quickly went into motherhood
and navigated that dynamic,
I believe the current
landscape of business,
which is becoming disproportionately
more emotional intelligence than skills.
Women from the 50's, 60's, 70's,
what we all grew up with it.
When the world in the
60's, 70's, 80's, 90's
were vocational, when
the skill was the value,
well then one would say ooh, that's tough.
You now have to learn a craft at 49.
I believe that we have now entered a world
where emotional
intelligence and management
is the most valuable disproportionate.
When you think of the
comps of running a family
as a mother, there's enormous
bandwidth and capability
of juggling a lot of emotions at one time.
I think we're going to see the golden era
of women that are going to
be able to have their cake
and eat it too that
starts right about now.
- [Woman] But they have
to learn to believe
in themselves first, right?
We don't have the courage.
- You'll appreciate this.
That's for every single
human being on Earth.
- Very true.
- Do you know
how many 49-year-old men do
not believe in themselves?
- Yep.
- Most.
So in the macro, of course.
- [Woman] But the belief got
us here with you today sitting.
We're coming from a little
small town in Canada.
- I get it.
- [Angela] We have a gift for you.
- I will wear it.
- Can you be our Friday babe?
- 100%.
- This is our belief.
- [Woman] Every Friday we do a babe.
Like she's our babe.
We have babes supporting
babes and that's our thing.
So you're our babe.
- You're our babe.
- Friday.
I'm not in the office Friday.
- [Woman] We're going to
take a picture with you.
- Let's do it.
- Then you can
verify everything.
- Thank you for everybody
listening on the podcast.
- Thank you.
- Happy holiday.
- [Woman] Remember, Theory
loves you. (laughing)
- This is amazing.
- [Woman] So that's a little present
to make up for the support.
- Amazing.
Let's do it, let's do it.
- Then of course we wore these shirts
because we bought all your wine.
- I saw, thank you so much.
You got it.
For the wall? 100%.
- That's your PJ man
for the wall.
- Seth, wall.
Wall.
- [Woman] Photos.
Can you guys, can you take the photos?
- [Man] All right, guys.
Just follow my camera.
(upbeat music)